Now that Java and Hadoop are installed,
you'll need to set a few environment
variables on the instance.
These will help applications
locate Java and Hadoop.
First thing you'll need to do is
note where open JDK is installed.
To find it you can use readlink like so.
This gives the path to
the Java executable.
But here we want the path
to the directory with jre
which is the Java runtime environment.
As you can see, mine was installed
at usr/lib/jvm/java-7-openjdk-amd64.
But yours might be different.
Probably this directory
you're going to use it next.
You're going to set the environment
variables in .bashrc.
So open the file in
your favorite editor.
First you're going to have a variable
that points to the Java installation.
You're also going to add
the bin directory to the path.
You also have a variable
that points to hadoop.
Finally add a variable that acts as
a shortcut to the hadoop configuration
directory.
This will come in handy later.
With these set, save the file and exit.
Finally load these
variables with source and
check to make sure those
things are set correctly.